[MUSIC PLAYING]
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: I'd like to
introduce Karen Page and Andrew
Dornenburg to talk today.
We're going to talk a little
bit about their new book, which
is in front of me,
"Kitchen Creativity,"
but this is also
their 11th book.
And I've been using your
books for multiple years
as inspiration from when I
was first cooking but also
now to help provide inspiration
to our chefs in our units
around the world at Google.
So thank you, first, for being
here and making time to see us.
It's a true pleasure.
But a little bit about
our authors before we
dive into the book.
And we would like to make
this kind of a conversation.
So if you have
questions that come up,
typically we'll leave
them to the end.
But if there's
something that you
have a tidbit you really want
to get out there, please let us
know.
We love to make
this a conversation.
And we're going to
do a quick interview,
and then we're going
to break into what
we do at Kitchen Sync, which
is our teaching kitchen.
We're going to do some cooking,
and Chef Dede and the team
are going to put together
a delicious treat.
And you will get to sample it.
So that's always a plus.
So a little bit
about our authors.
So for Karen, on my right
here-- after skipping a grade,
Karen received her
letter of admissions
to Northwestern
University at age 16.
The first--
KAREN PAGE: Oh, god, you're not
going to do the whole thing.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: No,
not the whole thing.
KAREN PAGE: My life
story is flashing by--
ANDREW DORNENBURG:
I know, right?
KAREN PAGE: --before my eyes.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: But
you were the first person
to attend college, self-financed
your education with seven
academic scholarships.
Super cool.
You ran your own
birthday cake delivery
business-- love to hear
more about that later on.
You were awarded
a BA in economics
and certified in
the women's studies
from Northwestern
University in '83.
Named one of six honorable
mentions in "Glamour's" Top
10 College Women
competition and featured
on the cover of "Newsweek."
As well, you were invited to the
White House twice back in '86.
You also earned an MBA from
Harvard Business School.
Northwestern named you, in '93,
one of the university's 100
leading professional alumni.
Congratulations.
KAREN PAGE: Council of 100.
Go Wildcats.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI:
An avid meditator.
You both like to run--
interesting to hear that.
And you live in New York
City with your husband
to your right, Andrew.
So welcome, Karen.
It's great to have you here.
And Mr. Andrew grew up
in the Bay Area here.
Great to see another
Bay Area individual.
And you kind of transitioned
from farmland to suburbs.
So your family's background and
backyard had a lot of trees.
You were obviously
into gardening,
and it led you into
the culinary world,
where you started
cooking at a young age.
And you were mentioned
as first cooking
at McDonald's in
your early years--
ANDREW DORNENBURG: Absolutely.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: --as
well as one of the few--
like Jeff Bezos and
others have also worked
at McDonald's, and doing quite
well now from McDonald's.
Congratulations.
ANDREW DORNENBURG: Thank you.
KAREN PAGE: Good to know.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Everyone
has their start somewhere.
That's awesome.
ANDREW DORNENBURG: Absolutely.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Three
days out of high school,
you became a firefighter.
So obviously with the
amazing devastation
in Northern California
with the fires lately,
it's great to see that you were
putting in your dues early on.
But at the same time, you
found that after a while,
firefighting was--
even though it was your
best day of putting out
fires and cooking for
the team, your best days
ahead were really
getting into the kitchen.
So you became a chef.
You worked in some amazingly
talented restaurants,
worked under some top chefs.
And then after deciding
to leave the kitchen--
I see you worked with
Lydia Shire for a while--
decided to leave
the kitchen and then
ended up putting together
some amazing books
that we're going to
talk about in a moment.
You also earned your
somm certificate--
interesting tidbit--
and--
KAREN PAGE: Actually,
we both did.
ANDREW DORNENBURG: Yes.
KAREN PAGE: Yes.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI:
At the same time?
ANDREW DORNENBURG: No.
KAREN PAGE: Different times.
But I think it's an
important part of anybody's
culinary education--
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Absolutely.
Absolutely.
KAREN PAGE: Worthwhile.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: And
then interesting piece
as well is you followed your--
was it your grandmother's
love for photography?
ANDREW DORNENBURG: Indeed.
My grandmother actually had a
dark room, which you probably
have no idea what it
is, but it was a place
where you developed film.
But you probably have no
idea what that is either.
There was a time where
that happened, yes.
So I followed that up.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: And so
you did all the photographs
for the book.
Is that correct?
KAREN PAGE: Yes.
ANDREW DORNENBURG:
Yes, for this one.
KAREN PAGE: For this one
and "Veg Flavor Bible" also.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Yeah, great.
So multi-talented
individuals here in the room.
ANDREW DORNENBURG: Indeed.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: So
it's my distinct pleasure
and total excitement--
I can't say it enough.
We talked and had coffee
for the last hour,
and how excited I was
to see you guys here.
Please welcome our authors.
[APPLAUSE]
KAREN PAGE: Well, I can't--
I have to interject by
saying, first of all, Scott,
thank you for that
amazing introduction.
I was worried we
were going to be here
for hours if you're starting out
at age 16, but that was lovely.
But the reason that
we're here is actually
because of this man.
And I haven't had the pleasure
of meeting him in person
before, but we have
been in email touch
and in virtual
touch ever since he
gave this wonderful interview
to this national magazine
where he mentioned
one of our books
is his favorite book, which
we actually got to see today,
which was thrilling.
I think it's bound together--
what were you describing?
With butcher string and kind
of falling apart a little bit.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI:
This is priceless.
So if anyone tries to take
this from me, good luck.
This is the first edition
"Culinary Artistry,"
and it is in the same condition
as it was 17 years ago
when you signed it.
It was literally signed in 2000.
And it was a book that
I used for inspiration
on a day-to-day level
when I was writing menus.
And we're going
to talk about how
chefs gain their inspiration and
how culinarians and even home
chefs, home cooks,
gain their inspiration.
And there's such a
variety of techniques
in becoming creative.
But this book is
something that's
very near and dear to me.
And when I brought
it out to Andrew
when he was dining
at our restaurant,
I humbly said, it's getting
used, as you can see,
because the binding's
falling off.
So my only feedback
for the publisher
is stronger binding,
because the butcher's twine
is not quite working.
ANDREW DORNENBURG: Or duct
tape included in the future.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI:
Yeah, exactly.
KAREN PAGE: But when you
talk about inspiration,
part of our inspiration
for being here
is really Scott and
the amazing reputation
that Google has for
its culinary program.
And to know that
you've been here for--
how many years now?
12?
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Yeah,
going on 12 years, yeah.
KAREN PAGE: --that you
have helped to have it--
raise it to really
a world-class level.
When you started
out, there was just,
I think, a handful of cafes.
And now, you know, there
they are all over the world.
But for those of us who have
never eaten at Google before--
this is a first--
to know that it is legendary in
terms of the choices available,
the quality of the food.
And now, being here at
this wonderful new location
that we understand just
opened a matter of weeks ago,
really, it's
something that gets us
on a plane from New York City
to come out to the Bay Area
to see what it's all about.
And the fact that if we had
any role, the most minute role
in being an inspiration
to you, then we're
thrilled to be able to
be here and to be here
with all the Googlers
for the first time.
So thank you for having us.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: I often
talk about your books.
Obviously, this has just
been released a week ago.
So many of you probably
haven't gotten it yet.
You're flipping through it.
But a lot of your books
follow that same theme,
which is to really unlock the
creativity and the potential
in chefs' minds.
And again, whether it's a
professional chef or whether
it's chefs at home.
And what I've found that these
books are so amazing at is--
I always say it's
hard to plan to be
creative on a specific day.
You can book the time in your
calendar and say, on Wednesday,
I'm going to write a menu.
But you know, you don't feel
well, the weather's bad,
something comes up in
the news, and you're
just-- you're not feeling it.
Tell me how this book is
helping chefs and individuals
kind of overcome that.
There's a lot of
great pieces in here.
But maybe unpack a little bit
of some of the initial thoughts
that you'd put into this
book to help chefs and home
chefs really kind of
get that creative edge
and bring their best forward.
KAREN PAGE: Sure.
Well, I think it's true
that for any of us who
cook, whether it's at
home or professionally,
you're always looking
for inspiration.
And there's a lot of
sameness, otherwise, that
takes place when you're
making the same thing day in
and day out.
So if you can learn to bring
creativity to your cooking,
it's going to add that
much more enjoyment to you,
to everybody that you're
cooking for and with.
But beyond that, it's
really a matter of--
creativity is the
most important skill
that we can possibly have.
And so if you can learn
the skill of creativity
from the world's best chefs,
what better way to learn it?
We had done research
on the fact that CEOs
are saying that the number one
skill for success in leadership
and in business is creativity.
It's not integrity.
It's not global thinking,
which is a little interesting.
But the fact that
it's creativity
makes it a subject
that's worth studying.
And so we also realize that
only one in four people surveyed
say that they think that they're
at their creative potential.
So to the extent that we
can become more creative,
it's something we can
apply to our daily lives.
It's something we can
apply in the kitchen.
And so what we did with
"Kitchen Creativity" is we
wanted to create the ultimate
culinary brainstorming tool.
So if you want to
be more creative,
what are some of the
things that you can use,
some of the best practices that
are used by the world's best
chefs to become more creative.
And really, we map
out the process
of creativity, which I know
we're going to get into.
But both in a general way, in
terms of culinarily coming up
with a new dish, trying
to take old dishes
and make them new again.
But then also from just a
best practices standpoint,
how do you let your
creativity flow?
And we've got some advice from
some of the leading creativity
experts in the world talking
about how to make that happen.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Yeah,
so don't downplay that.
I think one of the things that
got me excited about "Culinary
Artistry" when I
looked at it years ago
was the pedigree of chefs
you have in your back pocket.
I'm interested to
hear how you informed
some of the initial
relationships with these chefs.
You're talking about
every top chef out there.
Whether it's Danko, Ripert,
Danny Meyers, restaurateur,
you've got amazing chefs
that are taking their time
to share some of their
most intimate secrets
on what's made them successful.
And I don't take that lightly,
and none of our chefs at Google
that do such an amazing
job in bringing the food
program to life here do either.
These are the
inspirational chefs
that they look to aspire to be.
What were some of the initial--
how did that happen?
What was that first chef
that you were like, oh,
my god, if I could
just get this one to--
how did that go about?
KAREN PAGE: Well, you
know, when we started out,
we'd never written
a book before.
And so how do you get
the world's best chefs
to talk to you?
We didn't really know.
But the ace in our
hole was that Andrew
was working as a
professional chef in Boston,
and he was working with
Chris Schlesinger and Lydia
Shire, who at the time
were two of the best
chefs in the country, who
happened to be in Boston.
And so having-- starting
out with the two of them,
and then he went on to work
with Anne Rosenzweig at Arcadia
in New York City.
And once we had the three
of them in our pocket,
we could kind of go to people.
Because there was
three big names
that they knew us
personally that
had some belief that we
could actually write a book.
And so they thought, well, if
Lydia's in, and Chris is in,
and Anne's in, then I'm in, too.
So from there, we went
to other top chefs
in Boston and New York.
Then we were doing the research
on weekends and evenings.
We would travel to San Francisco
and knock on Gary Danko's door.
Actually, you had also worked
with Madeleine at that point.
ANDREW DORNENBURG: I worked
with Madeleine Kamman
up at the School for American
Chefs at Beringer Vineyards.
And so we met Gary Danko.
We met other chefs
through her, too.
But the key is Karen
writes a great letter.
That's how you do it.
She goes, well, we've just
interviewed these other people.
Would you like to be
included in our new book?
And even though they didn't know
us, they knew the other people.
And it's like-- and also,
asking for 15 minutes.
We only need 15, 20 minutes.
And that always, almost
always, turned into an hour.
And I'll never forget we
interviewed Chef Barbara
Tropp, a legendary restaurateur
and chef, China Moon
Cafe in San Francisco.
And at the end-- we talked for
almost an hour and a half--
she goes, I've never had
a conversation like this.
And we're like, neither have we.
And then she's like, try not
to edit my words too much.
We're like, you
went to Princeton.
You're good.
KAREN PAGE: PhD in
Chinese poetics.
She spoke in poetry.
Just an amazing woman,
founder of the Women Chefs
and Restaurateurs
Association that we
talked about was near and
dear to Dede and myself,
as a former board
member of that.
So I think once you
kind of get started,
then it is easier to
get the ball rolling.
And that's true of any
aspect of creativity.
The Goethe quote, it's like,
whatever you can imagine--
and I won't get the words
right, but you know, be bold.
Take action.
And then it really
has a magic to it
that really starts to unfold.
So once you take action
in a certain direction--
we talk in the book-- there's
an A to Z section of the book,
the back of the book.
That is laid out
like "Flavor Bible,"
if any of you are
familiar with that,
where it's a three-column
format, A to Z.
But instead of flavors--
we have apples to zucchini
in "The Flavor Bible"--
we have every other topic under
the sun, from architecture to--
ANDREW DORNENBURG:
"Alice in Wonderland."
KAREN PAGE: "Alice
in Wonderland."
ANDREW DORNENBURG:
And there's actually
a restaurant based on "Alice
in Wonderland," the book.
And we actually
finish up with yoga.
Rick Bayless of the Frontera
Grill and Topolobampo,
the restaurant of the year
and the James Beard Award--
he's been doing
yoga for 20 years.
And this is what's
fun about knowing
these people for so long.
It's like, hey, Rick, would you
mind doing a yoga pose for us?
So he's in a chef's jacket.
And he just pops up on the
counter and does yoga for us.
And so it's like--
KAREN PAGE: He's amazing.
ANDREW DORNENBURG:
He's like, sure.
KAREN PAGE: For as long
as we've known him--
because we interviewed Rick
Bayless for all of our books--
we had never seen him do
this amazing pose before.
But you know, anyone as
multi-talented as Rick,
who has been doing yoga for
20 years, it's pretty awesome.
So what an inspiration
to talk to chefs.
And again, you know,
when you're talking
to chefs for your 11th book
as opposed to your first book,
it's a whole different
ballgame, because you built up
a certain level of
knowledge and trust.
And so we're talking to people
about what inspires them,
and they went a little,
you know, rogue with us.
ANDREW DORNENBURG:
They went there.
KAREN PAGE: They went there.
And they could tell
us quite honestly,
you know, I look
at my ingredients.
I talk to my ingredients.
And so I'll take an
apple, and I'll put it
in the center of the table.
And I'll have a
conversation with the apple
and say, OK, apple, what
are we going to do today?
You've done some
interesting things before,
but what are we
going to do today?
And there is this
level of intuition.
You could call it
mediumship, channeling,
whatever you want to call
it, that takes place.
And we're talking about the most
respected chefs in the country.
So Jose Andres, based
in Washington, DC,
will talk to his ingredients.
He said, if you talk
to your ingredients,
they will always
tell you a story.
You just have to have your
ears open to hear that story.
Ghaya Oliveira, who just won
the James Beard Award this year,
is the best outstanding pastry
chef in the United States.
She's the one who puts the
apple on the parchment paper
in the center of Restaurant
Daniel in New York City
and says, talk to me, apple.
Phillip Foss from EL
Ideas in Chicago--
ANDREW DORNENBURG: Yeah.
Phillip Foss, he's great.
This is a very
fascinating restaurant.
It's in a loft way out
in the middle of nowhere.
They say take a car.
You know, don't take
public transportation.
But he will say, the
ingredient is my child.
And I want my child to
succeed and be happy.
And it's up to me to
care for the child
and make sure it's
physically, emotionally,
and mentally, and
spiritually happy.
So he treats his ingredients
like they're children
and raises them and, again,
has that conversation.
And he has the craziest
menu I think I've ever seen.
He will do a menu
based on the '80s.
He will produce a dish and
play a certain piece of music
that it's inspired by.
KAREN PAGE: Madonna's
"Like A Virgin,"
he's got a little
dish to go with that.
He'll serve "cocaine,"
which is basically
a lime and coconut powder on
a mirror with a razor blade,
at his Michelin-starred
restaurant.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: I think
our chefs are getting inspired.
I hear them giggling.
KAREN PAGE: He's out there.
But he's got a Michelin
star, and he's respected.
He's so celebrated.
And so, you know,
there are chefs out
there who are creative.
They're pushing the envelope.
And they're doing a lot of
things that are a lot of fun.
And you might not serve exactly
the same things in a home,
but you can be inspired
by the thought process.
He does a dish of Frosties
and french fries, which
was inspired by his daughters.
Was a single dad for a
while and raising his kids,
and the babysitter took
them to Wendy's, where
they learned to dip their--
did anybody do that?
Dip their french
fries in the Frosty?
ANDREW DORNENBURG: I'd
never heard of that, yeah.
KAREN PAGE: Did you ever
have it in a Michelin starred
restaurant?
If you go to EL
Ideas in Chicago,
you can taste it there.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: So what
I love about these books,
again, is that it caters
to a variety of audiences.
You've got people that
are cooking at home.
are beginning to cook
or learning to cook.
Or you've got people that have
been cooking for many years.
What I love about
this, in essence,
is that it's very similar
to our program here.
We're really trying to enable
people to pick up skills
and give them the confidence.
And when you dive
into the book, you're
going to see that
the quotes in here
are not only from some of
the biggest and baddest names
out there, but they're the
really great tidbits that
really help unpack
what they're thinking
and their thought process.
So let's think-- let's talk
a little bit about the book.
So the book is very interesting.
This is a book of no recipes.
This is a book--
and thank you, because there's
a lot of recipes out there--
but it's really around
a few different aspects.
So you start the
book around mastery.
And so there's a
section on that, which
I'd love to talk about briefly.
And then section two
is more around alchemy,
the transformation stage.
And then number three
is around, really,
that creativity aspect, which
obviously is the bulk of it.
Can you talk about the
three different sections
briefly so we can kind of
get an understanding of why
you went that direction?
And then we'll bring
in some examples.
KAREN PAGE: Sure.
Well, we start out with
mastery, because, as Picasso
lets us know, you can't
break the rules unless you
know what the rules are.
So you start out by
understanding the rules.
And the way to do that
is really to learn
to think like a chef, shop like
a chef, and season like a chef.
And so in terms of
thinking like a chef,
we have done lots of
research on the leading books
that chefs everywhere
say that you
should have in your
culinary library at home.
And we've narrowed it
down to the 20 top books.
And if you read these
books, if you really
absorb that information,
you're going
to know what the
best chefs know.
And that will give
you a starting point
in terms of knowledge.
In terms of skill,
you want to learn to--
well, actually, one other thing
that's important with chefs
is the shopping aspect.
This shopping is a
skill that if you
aren't willing to invest in
the same level of ingredients
that the best chefs
work with, you're not
going to have the same results.
Sometimes the hardest
part is figuring
out-- where do you buy it?
And chefs have already
done that hard work for you
to find the very best
of the best ingredients.
We have a list of the
purveyors that provide chefs
with some of the hard to find
ingredients, spices, herbs,
seasonings.
ANDREW DORNENBURG:
Lots of grains, too.
KAREN PAGE: Yes.
ANDREW DORNENBURG: Yeah,
lots of grains and flowers.
They all want their
polenta milled
a certain way or their
flour milled a certain way.
KAREN PAGE: So we've got a guide
to where to shop like a chef.
And then in terms of
seasoning like a chef,
that's really what we were
talking about in "Culinary
Artistry" so many years ago.
When we banished chefs
to a desert island
and asked them to bring only
10 ingredients that they would
cook with for the
rest of their life,
the number one
ingredient was salt.
And salt is really
the master technique.
All the chefs in the room are
nodding their heads like, yes,
of course.
But to learn to add sodium to
a dish in a way that enhances
flavor without necessarily
adding flavor, which
we get into in the
alchemy stage of things,
but it gets a little
more complicated.
Above and beyond
"The Flavor Bible,"
we talk about different
elements of salt. So not
just which salt do
different chefs use--
some use sea salt. Some use
mined salt. Some use pink salt.
There are different salts
for different purposes.
And thinking more
specifically about the salt
you use, adding not only
sodium, but in some cases umami
through a salty ingredient,
or other ingredients
that are complex, that will add
more than one taste at once.
If you learn how
to work with them,
it can really
elevate your cooking.
We talked to one chef the
other night in New York City.
We did an event.
And he was talking
about the fact
that he actually
ran out of salt,
which was the first
chef I've ever heard--
but it happens.
We're all human.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: I've
never heard that before.
ANDREW DORNENBURG: That's the
exact reaction everybody had.
KAREN PAGE: I think
it was at home.
Maybe he wouldn't run out of it
at the restaurant, but at home.
But he opened up his
refrigerator at home,
and he had feta cheese there.
So he took the liquid from
the feta, which is salty,
and he used that as sort
of a liquid salt, ad hoc.
And you know, it's just
one of those things
that it's like,
well, of course you
could use salty ingredients.
It doesn't have to be salt.
And I think part of what
"Kitchen Creativity" is all
about is how can you open your
mind to thinking not about
specific ingredients,
but thinking
about concepts that
you're adding to a dish
and to use it and really
extrapolate from there.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: It's
interesting to think
through the whole aspect
of just seasoning,
because people think, oh, you
just add salt, and it's done.
Well, there's types of
salt. There's layering,
when to add the
salt, when to add it
in the beginning and
the end of cooking.
And these are the tips that
are within the book that really
help a good chef
become a great chef,
and a great chef become an
excellent chef, whether, again,
you're a home chef or not.
So the first stage is mastery.
And you made it very clear
that-- and all the chefs
said this in the book-- that
to be able to master anything,
it's a lot of practice.
It's a lot of discipline.
It's a lot of time.
And once you
understand the rules,
then you can attempt
to break the rules.
And then I think it kind of
takes you to that next step.
So talk to them about
the next section,
which is around that
transformation and alchemy
stage.
KAREN PAGE: Well,
that's the stage
that we've really been
writing about and talking
about for years now under
the guise of "Culinary
Artistry," "The Flavor
Bible," and "What to
Drink with What You Eat."
So alchemy is really about, how
do you take something common
and turn it into
something precious?
And what we mean by
that is that there
is a benefit in the culinary
world that one plus one
doesn't just equal two.
There are instances
in which one plus one
can equal three or more.
And what we have dedicated
our research to over the years
is trying to identify what is
the lock that you can put--
the key that you can put
into the lock to really turn
it to unlock the deliciousness
of particular ingredients,
whether they're herbs or
spices or other seasonings
for specific ingredients.
And this is what led us
both to sommelier school
is realizing that if you've
got a perfect plate of food
in front of you, and you've got
the wrong wine in your glass,
when you have the two together--
which you inevitably do,
because you eat and drink
together-- it's going to clash.
It's going to ruin the food.
So we became committed to
studying wine and earning
our sommelier
certificates, because it
was so important to--
it was an important
way to master flavor.
And that was the
best means that we
had to be able to
train our palates
and to learn more about, well,
what was the secret to matching
the best wines with food.
And so we also interviewed
dozens of the best sommeliers
all across the
country, including
at some of the top restaurants
and people that you're
well acquainted with, and
really compiled that into "What
to Drink With What
You Eat," which
is the ultimate food
and wine pairing guide,
because you can
look up the food.
It will tell you what wine
or beer, spirits, cocktails,
water, coffee, tea, et cetera
to drink with it to enhance
the flavor of that food.
Vice versa, if you're starting
with a bottle of wine,
you're starting
with a beer, you're
starting with something
else, what food can you
serve with it to best
enhance what's in the bottle
or what's in the glass?
And so when you bring all
of those elements together,
that's really what we're talking
about in terms of alchemy.
If you master some of
the principles of-- what
are the key flavor pairings?
What are the key--
some of those
standard-- you know,
sancerre and oysters or
pinot noir and salmon.
If you master some
of those, it gets
you so close to the ballpark
that you could actually
be only an OK chef with
a modicum of talent.
But if you understand
those principles
and can apply them
in the kitchen,
it's going to make you
shine to a whole new level.
ANDREW DORNENBURG: Yeah.
And we always talk about--
think about what's in the
glass as a sauce, also.
And again, you know,
a really easy way
to do that, a quick tool
is if it grows together,
it goes together.
So if you're in Italy,
and you're making pasta
from Northern Italy, see what
they drink in Northern Italy.
If you're in the Bay Area,
and you're grilling a steak,
well, gosh, grab
a bottle of zin.
You know, they're right
there in Napa Valley.
They're all next to each other.
There's a natural synergy.
But also, I think
it's also fun--
and just to wrap this
part up a little bit--
is that it's not just wine.
You can have a lemon
soda with a salad,
and that could almost be
your dressing on the salad.
So you think outside--
just think of the
classic pairings,
and we all know that
you can actually drink
white wine with many things.
You can actually drink
red wine with fish now.
It's OK.
Pinot noir and salmon.
So think of all the beverages
with what you can bring in.
And again, that's going to
change a lot of your meals
just by having the
proper beverage.
You know?
That's the three there.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: I think
you hit on a lot of key points,
and it goes much deeper than
just the actual dishes itself.
It goes to what's being
paired, your surroundings,
and it creates that
experience that if any of you
think about your most
epic food experience
you've ever had-- it could
be a hot dog at a ballpark,
it could be at a Michelin
star restaurant--
there's different things
that all came together.
And a great culinarian
makes that look so easy.
And a lot of these
tips are in the book.
And so it's super exciting.
There's a great
quote in the book,
and it starts off by saying
to not copy other chefs.
But to be able to get
inspired, I and many others
feel that copying is actually
the gateway to get into.
Can you speak to that?
Because it's kind
of a contradiction,
but it actually
makes total sense.
KAREN PAGE: Yes,
well, that's sort
of the hook in the
beginning of the book
is talking about-- we want
to teach you creativity.
What's the definition
of creativity?
It's not copying, coming
up with something that's
new and useful and surprising.
And yet by
definition, how do you
get to that point of
being able to do it?
You need to learn the rules.
How do you learn the rules?
You copy.
So that's the push me, pull you.
And I think that
that is a lesson that
comes through time and time
again in the book in that it's
never one or the other.
It's never hot versus cold.
It's both.
In the back of the
book under Y, you'll
find "yes, and" being
one of the key rules
that you need to
master for creativity.
And it's the first
rule of improvisation.
If you've ever done any
improvisational acting,
you know that if someone
says something like, OK,
here's the premise
of this scene.
I'm going to walk in, and I
dropped the book on the floor.
You don't say, oh, no, no,
no, you didn't drop the book.
You have to say, yes,
you dropped the book,
and that was the book
that I was on the waitlist
for at the library.
It's like, yes, and
that was the book
that my ex-boyfriend
actually wrote.
And you add onto the story.
So you always add on to
it, because you never
want to break that chain.
So the key that you can take
from the improvisational rules
and to apply in the kitchen
is no matter what happens,
you trust that it's
there to serve you,
and it's for a reason.
And what we tell people
is it kind of goes--
if you look in the
beginning of the book,
there's a list of
different classic dishes
and what their origins were.
And a lot of times,
they came from mistakes.
So there was something
that went wrong.
The burrito gets knocked
into the deep fat fryer.
Hey, chimichangas.
Or the ravioli gets knocked
into the deep fat fryer.
Hey, toasted ravioli
turns into a thing.
People love it.
So things are never really
mistakes if you pay attention
to it.
And so at Craftsman and
Wolves in San Francisco,
the intern undercooks the
egg that you asked her
to hard boil.
It's soft boiled.
It oozes out.
Wait a second.
That's kind of cool.
And you find out that
people love things
that ooze out of other things.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: You
just let all the secrets out
of our mistakes.
[LAUGHTER]
Thanks, Karen.
KAREN PAGE: There
are no mistakes.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: It's
a really good point.
I think Ferran Adria talks
in the book about the fact
that if you're
unique, and if you're
doing something innovative that
no one else has done before,
and you're not
copying, then no one
can really judge it
against anything else.
And I think that's a good point.
But you cannot go that
direction unless you've got
the understanding of the
technique and the mastery
to begin with.
And obviously, Ferran is one
of the most acclaimed chefs
out there, and so he can
easily pull that off.
But I think it's
a great testament
to get inspired by seeing
what other people do,
have conversations.
Whatever your inspiration
is to document it.
And you have a lot of
great tips in the book
around, how do you capture
that moment of creativity?
It's about always
being positive.
It's about surrounding
yourself with others
on great conversations.
It's about writing things down.
And you know, most
chefs, great chefs,
have either a pocketbook--
KAREN PAGE: A notebook.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: --a pen--
notebook, yeah.
KAREN PAGE: The
pen behind the ear.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Or
right by the bedside.
Because when you wake
up, sometimes you've
had this amazing thought or--
for me, it's if I exercise.
It's like I get that a-ha
moment of that would work.
And then, you know, you
have to write it down.
And it's about all these great
little tips that sometimes
are not revolutionary.
It's just, yes, this
makes total sense.
Let's do this more often.
And you can take that
outside the kitchen, as well.
KAREN PAGE: Yes,
and that was one
of the benefits of being
able to do book number 11
is because chefs were
really upfront with us
about their creative
process involving,
in a lot of cases,
personal reflection time.
So whether that was
through journaling
or through meditation--
we found out
that a lot of the chefs we've
been talking to for years
were very deep meditators.
Talked with Eric Ripert
of Le Bernardin, which
is on the world's
50 best restaurants
list, about his Tibetan
Buddhist meditation practice
that he credits as a
source of his creativity.
Mario Batali studied
TM after being
recommended to it by Jerry
Seinfeld, of all people.
And so he studied through
the David Lynch Foundation.
And other chefs are big
meditators, yoga doers,
martial artists, runners.
ANDREW DORNENBURG:
A lot of runners.
KAREN PAGE: For those
of us who are runners,
like Andrew and
I run marathons--
when you're doing 26.2 miles,
you know, it's all mental.
It's not physical anymore.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: It's
a grueling business.
It's very, very-- you
bring out all your senses
when you're cooking.
How many people here
love to cook at home?
KAREN PAGE: All right.
ANDREW DORNENBURG: Yay.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI:
Everyone here.
KAREN PAGE: Our kind of peeps.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: You're
going to be so more inspired now
with this book.
But it brings out all of it.
And it's very draining.
It's very emotionally draining,
sometimes more than even
physically draining, depending
on what you're doing.
And I think that
whatever you need
to do to create that balance is
going to keep you at your best
so that you can be at
your best consistently.
Because, you know, we're
human, and if we're not
feeling creative, that
speaks in the food.
You can see it.
You can smell it.
You can taste it.
Or you can't, right?
KAREN PAGE: And [INAUDIBLE]
calls that the aura of a dish.
That the most important
aspect of the dish
is that connection
between the dish itself
and the person who's eating it.
And she believes it's love.
That you can actually taste
it if there's soul in a dish,
if there's love in a
dish, or if there's not.
If a dish falls flat, she
knows that people just
aren't cooking with everything
that they can bring to a dish.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Sure.
So we're going to do
a transition here.
And speaking of
bringing everything
that we can to a dish, we're
going to do a little fun here
with Chef Dede and the team.
So we're in the
Kitchen Sync teaching
kitchen at Google in Sunnyvale.
And the team here is going
to talk through-- we're
going to move the
chairs out-- they're
going to talk through kind of
how they look at inspiration
when they create meals and
recipes for our Googlers
as they teach them to cook.
And we'll be kind of
narrating back and forth
and asking her all
sorts of questions
and seeing how it comes to life.
But I'm excited for this.
So, Chef Dede, welcome.
DEDE SAMPSON: Thank you, Scott.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Let
me get out of your way.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
So tell the audience here, and
obviously our virtual audience,
a little bit about what you
do and what Kitchen Sync is.
For the folks in the audience,
they probably understand it,
but you're delivering
cooking classes to Googlers.
DEDE SAMPSON: Yes.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI:
Sometimes families.
DEDE SAMPSON:
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: And
you're teaching people
on a variety spectrum,
whether they know how to cook,
they're comfortable
cooking, or not at all.
DEDE SAMPSON: Yep.
Sometimes we have people that
cook six, seven nights a week.
Sometimes they're just
getting into the kitchen,
and they want some basic
knife skills and basic cooking
techniques.
So we have a full
culinary program,
single-subject classes--
could be food literacy
based, skill building.
We do a core culinary
program, lots of team events,
guest chefs, so usually
two classes a day or more.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: You do
have the coolest job on campus.
[LAUGHTER]
DEDE SAMPSON: Yeah, I get to
live in this amazing space each
and every day.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: And you're
in a brand new teaching kitchen
here.
So I'm going to move that
chair out of your way.
And why don't you just
talk a little about--
I know I have kind of an
understanding of what you're
looking through here, but I
was talking to Karen and Andrew
earlier about what I
call the chef's arsenal.
And the chef's arsenal,
for many chefs, is--
especially in the older
days when we were trained--
you've got sugar, you've
got salt, you've got fat,
whatever that fat might be.
And those are the three
things that typically
dominate and deliver flavor.
And we still use
those, but we use
them a lot more thoughtfully.
We have a very
intentional outlook
on the food program at Google.
And while we want to
deliver on deliciousness--
and I love the fact
that you said that,
and that it's in
the book-- while we
want to deliver
on deliciousness,
we can do this in
thoughtful ways.
And so you're going to
talk through your dish
today, and kind of
how you're doing that
with the Google twist,
and talk through
some of the ingredients that are
your modern-day arsenal, that
are still delivering on the
attributes of sweet, sugar,
salty, and fat, but you're
doing them in a thoughtful way.
DEDE SAMPSON: Yeah,
so one of things
I think about when I'm
building out a dish,
start with seasonality.
I think that's really important.
And thinking about
the dish today,
I just was thinking about
all these amazing fall
squashes that are
coming into the market.
So we roasted up some
butternut squash.
We have some delicata
squash roasted as well.
And then thinking
about other ingredients
that would go well with this
dish, so some nice kale,
mushrooms-- and not only
mushrooms, roasted mushrooms.
So some roasted
shiitake mushrooms
really get into super tasty,
salty, umami for sure.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: So you're
talking about roasting a lot.
And for those who can't see
the ingredients up close,
you're developing a
heightened sense of the flavor
by the caramelization of the
natural sugars in the squash.
And the mushrooms-- you're
extracting the water
to get more flavor.
And so you're really
delivering on flavor.
And most of this, if not all
of it, is all plant based,
and so you're highlighting
the seasonality
as we're heading into fall.
We have some of
the squashes here,
but you've got some staples
that are always on our menus.
Whether it's the quinoa or the
mushrooms and things like that.
DEDE SAMPSON: Roasted
shallots as well, so yeah.
Really nice, plant-based dish,
one of the things we also
drive in Kitchen Sync as well.
And then, yeah, thinking about--
you could take this
set of ingredients,
and then I think
about, OK, how am I
going to build flavor with
a sauce or the dressing
or the sparkling water
and the wine, right?
So today I wanted to take a kind
of a trip in a map to Thailand
and use some Thai ingredients.
KAREN PAGE: Oh, excellent.
DEDE SAMPSON: So things
like fish sauce, right?
Salty, umami, it's that layer
of salt that's not just salt.
ANDREW DORNENBURG:
Caramelization, too, a lot
of flavor in there.
DEDE SAMPSON: Soy sauce.
Another, you know, fermented
sauces, fermented flavors,
really rich in umami.
Palm sugar, little bit of
sweet, but also just not--
KAREN PAGE: Balance?
DEDE SAMPSON: Yeah, right.
Kind of caramely, vanilla-y,
not just that plain white sugar
thing happening out there.
Fresh ginger, or classically,
for Thai, galangal root.
Thai chilis, a little
bit of that heat
and that sensory that you want.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI:
I'm already hungry.
KAREN PAGE: I know.
I am, too.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: I'm
going to pause you right now,
because you've delivered on
so many attributes that are
so important to any great meal.
And obviously,
within our guidance
that we provide to
our chefs, we have
a saying called flavor rules.
Flavor rules.
It has to be there,
or why bother?
Just go home.
Pack it up.
But there's also
rules of flavor.
And what Dede's
talked about is you've
got amazing flavors here.
And they happen
to be plant-based,
but they don't have to be.
You've got umami, that sixth
sense of that meatiness
through mushrooms, soy sauce.
You've got the spice
through ginger.
You've got spice through
sriracha or chili.
You've got the herbaceousness
from the cilantro.
You've got the
crunch from the nuts.
You've got all these
different aspects
that for a dish to
truly be craveable,
for you to want
one more bite, you
need to get all of
these elements together.
And what Dede is going to do
now is to pull these together
in a way that is going
to want the diner
to go back for that next bite.
And as our focus
here-- where we're
trying to help our users make
better choices with food,
because the food here
is something that
is plentiful and
bountiful-- it's
easy to make wrong decisions.
And our job is to make it easier
for you to make better choices
and to enjoy what you have.
Because a lot of times
users come to us and say,
this is the highlight of my day.
Lunch was, like, the highlight.
So it should be--
ANDREW DORNENBURG: Way to go.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI:
--an amazing experience.
ANDREW DORNENBURG: That's great.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Hopefully.
No one's saying no.
KAREN PAGE: Look at
the smiles out there.
Yeah.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: So,
Dede, why don't you dive in.
And if the audience
has questions,
you guys can chime in while Dede
starts putting this together.
KAREN PAGE: You picked some of
my favorite complements to--
I love this combination
of squash and mushrooms,
the earthiness balancing
the sweetness of the squash.
I think it's still
seasonal, and yet there's
a real complementary
nature to that.
ANDREW DORNENBURG: And
actually, the other thing I like
is the fact of the nuts.
The nuts will crunch, but also
it's protein and it's fat.
So when you were talking
about fat being such--
playing a role--
and it still does.
And fat is actually soon
to be considered a flavor.
But that's a good way to
make the dish even healthier
as opposed to, like,
a creamy dressing
or something like that.
You can get it all there.
So you're actually
getting two for one.
Actually, a little
bit of umami, too.
That's a really key thing.
And who doesn't
like crunchy nuts?
DEDE SAMPSON: Walnut.
You know how we were
talking about earlier
that kind of stealing,
that taking advice?
I did check out the book, of
course, before you got here,
and I saw the mushroom advice.
And I was like, right, I got
to put the mushrooms in there.
So thank you.
KAREN PAGE: There you go.
You've obviously read
well and paid attention.
And of course, quinoa, with
its high protein content--
I always feel virtuous
when I have it.
I love the texture.
It's more of a textural thing
for me, I think, than flavor.
But I love the earthiness
of it, the knowing
that I'm doing something
good for my body.
Yes.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: So there's
a beautiful array of colors.
For those that are up
here, you can smell it.
And it's a cold dish.
So imagine if some
of these were heated,
and you could easily add the
warm mushrooms or warm squash.
And temperature
plays a lot into what
we do as we're creating dishes,
because you eat with your eyes
first.
But even before that is
if you walk into any cafe
or restaurant, the first
thing you generally get
is a smell of something,
and hopefully something
that's not overpowering
like cologne or perfume--
which is why chefs don't wear--
yeah, that's beautiful-- which
is why chefs don't wear that.
KAREN PAGE: So refreshing.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI:
One of the things
that I'd love Dede
to speak to is
the disciplines within
the program at Google
about really practicing
your recipes.
This is something that
you've made before.
It's not something that
you see on "Top Chef"
where you get five ingredients,
and you put something together,
and it's perfect day one.
And the reason I mention
that-- and I love the TV
shows that have really
brought the popularity of food
and getting people excited.
But at times I think there
is a challenge out there
that a lot of people
think that just throwing
ingredients together is
the way it is for chefs.
And that's not the case.
They spend so much time
testing and training
and retesting and retooling.
And what we call
a signature recipe
might take us weeks, months,
or years to get to a point.
And talk a little bit
about your thought process
and how you got this,
because I know you just
didn't go in the
refrigerator and be like, ah,
that looks like fun today.
You had some thought with this.
So give us some insights as
you're compiling this, please.
DEDE SAMPSON: Yeah, absolutely.
So like I said, back to
seasonality, deliciousness,
craveability, you
know, super important.
And so going back to roasting
the butternut squash,
thinking about the fish sauce,
all those fermented things--
I'm actually
surprised I didn't put
miso paste on this, because
I'm obsessed with miso paste
right now.
KAREN PAGE: It's always better
with miso or often better
with miso.
Great, magic ingredient.
DEDE SAMPSON: So I'll
put a bit of miso
into a salad dressing or,
you know, adding into a dish.
KAREN PAGE: And I love what you
said about roasting the squash,
because again, every ingredient
also has a key that unlocks it
in terms of technique.
You don't boil it.
You don't steam it.
You roast it to get
the ultimate flavor.
DEDE SAMPSON: Yeah, great point.
You know, adding in the crunch
with some of the red bell
peppers and also a
little bit of sweetness.
We roasted the
shallots, as well.
ANDREW DORNENBURG: Really
concentrated flavor.
DEDE SAMPSON: Another tip
I stole from the book.
KAREN PAGE: Excellent.
DEDE SAMPSON: And then, you
know, we balance taste, right?
The sweet, the sour, the salty,
the bitter, and the umami.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: It's
like chef's favorite two
words-- needs salt. I
think even in the book.
You joke that chefs can look at
a dish and say, it needs salt.
And 9 times out of
10, they're right.
So you're about to
put this together,
and obviously the team
is-- and right now Jared's
tasting to make sure
that the salt is spot on.
ANDREW DORNENBURG:
But that's good.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI:
But it's so key.
How many people here
have cooked at home,
and there's always
some-- there's that one
little element missing, right?
It could be salt.
It could be acid.
It could be that balance.
And that's the
fun in the kitchen
is to come up with what is that
perfect balance that you're
looking for.
And what Dede's got here
is a perfect opportunity
to deliver on an
amazing deliciousness,
because you've got
all that going on.
But with Thai food
specifically, it's
either really good or
really wrong, right?
Because if you're too
high on the sugar,
if you're too high on the spice,
it just throws the balance off.
And so what she's doing
now is she's going through,
and she's looking for
those specific balances
and incorporating
the ingredients.
How is it tasting?
JARED: It's good.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Do you
need Dede to check that?
You sound kind of confident.
KAREN PAGE: I think
with the sweetness,
you know, sweetness
gets a bad rap
that you don't want
to eat too much sugar,
which I think is true,
but also sometimes
all you need is a little bit of
sugar to be a flavor enhancer.
And you get-- and there's that
peak aspect of when you're
looking how to season
where you learn,
OK, it's enhancing flavor,
enhancing, enhancing, oops,
it starts dulling flavor.
And so if you add
too much sugar,
it will dull the flavors.
So you kind of have
to work on getting
to the peak of that apex
as it's still going up
and then before it
starts going down.
And I think that's just a matter
of trial and error, repetition,
as you said before--
ANDREW DORNENBURG:
Personal taste.
KAREN PAGE: Personal
taste, in some instances.
Yeah.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI:
And that's a challenge.
Personal taste, obviously,
with hundreds of thousands
of Googlers running around--
our approach on
that is to create
food that is
approachable for everyone
but personalizable
for everyone as well.
And so a lot of the times,
we'll leave garnishes
on the side purposely
so that people
could add their element of
acidity, spice, et cetera.
And I find myself doing
that more and more
when I cook at home, because
everyone has different tastes.
So question for both of you.
If you had three
ingredients that are always
in your refrigerator
that you would rely on
for instant flavor--
KAREN PAGE: I love
that question.
And it always changes, right?
Miso is absolutely one of the--
ANDREW DORNENBURG: And it
changes during the season, too.
KAREN PAGE: We
have to have miso--
well, champagne.
I don't know about
that ingredient,
but you just always
need champagne on hand.
DEDE SAMPSON:
We're in alignment.
KAREN PAGE: Is
that an ingredient?
DEDE SAMPSON:
We're in alignment.
KAREN PAGE: Right, right.
DEDE SAMPSON: Champagne
is very important.
KAREN PAGE: I'm
getting that sense.
ANDREW DORNENBURG: It is
always in the refrigerator.
KAREN PAGE: What else?
ANDREW DORNENBURG:
Parmesan cheese.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Yes.
ANDREW DORNENBURG: Parmesan
is a real workhorse.
KAREN PAGE: Actually, we
ate vegan for two months.
And we found that it
was really hard to live
without Parmesan cheese.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI:
Yeah, why would you
want to do that, right?
KAREN PAGE: Yeah.
ANDREW DORNENBURG: Yeah.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: All right.
Miso, Parmesan, so I'm
picking up two umami things.
ANDREW DORNENBURG: And
then, actually, not in
the refrigerator, but on the--
next to the stove is always
a wide variety of vinegars.
Champagne, sherry, balsamic,
white balsamic, dark balsamic.
And what's cool about
vinegar is I think this is--
if you want to be
more creative tonight,
buy a different bottle of
vinegar, make your same salad,
and do one with balsamic
vinegar tonight,
one with a squeeze
of lemon tomorrow,
and one with champagne
vinegar the next day.
You'll have three
completely different salads.
And also, vinegars have
different degrees of acidity,
too.
So champagne vinegar
is very soft.
Lemon's relatively soft.
So we always have
a lot of vinegar.
So it's basically salt, sour--
KAREN PAGE: Actually,
and Saison sauce.
ANDREW DORNENBURG:
Oh, and Saison sauce.
Joshua Skenes' Saison.
We got a little bottle
of that after we left.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: How
many people are feeling
inspired to cook tonight?
[LAUGHTER]
KAREN PAGE: You
know, the thing is
that if you have those
key ingredients, whatever
they are-- and I think it
changes from week to week,
because we don't like having
the same thing every night.
So some nights, it's
like, OK, we better
have rice and
beans and avocados,
because that'll get us
in the Mexican realm.
We want to have a
good salsa on hand,
either a fresh pico de gallo
or a great jarred salsa.
And just be able to throw those
elements together very quickly
so that you can eat in a
different country every night
of the week if you've
got-- or every week you
can sort of shake it up if you
want to use some leftovers.
But when we're in a pasta mood,
we want to have pasta on hand.
We'll have pesto.
We love the combination of
pasta, pesto, white beans.
You know, it's one of
those 10, 15 minute meals
that you boil up the pasta--
sometimes even authors
who write about food
don't want to be
that ambitious to do
a recipe that takes an hour.
You just want something--
OK, I want something delicious.
I want it in 15 minutes.
The combination of the pesto
and white bean and pasta
is a staple.
And then we throw
in some greens,
because you want to have some
nutritional value in there.
ANDREW DORNENBURG:
Actually, spinach
is a huge workhorse
in our kitchen.
Because with spinach,
it can go into a pasta.
It can go into a salad.
KAREN PAGE: It could
go into a curry.
ANDREW DORNENBURG:
And it's so funny.
Because when I was
looking at this, really
what made this dish
special is the fact
you decided to take
it to Thailand.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI:
It smells great.
ANDREW DORNENBURG: But if I
looked at these ingredients--
KAREN PAGE: Beautiful.
ANDREW DORNENBURG: --I could
easily turn this into chili,
you know?
It's like, this would
be my chili at home--
squash, greens, mushrooms.
KAREN PAGE: Beans.
ANDREW DORNENBURG:
Yeah, beans, and you
can go to a completely
different place.
So the question we'll use
at night is like, well,
what country do I feel
like being in tonight?
And sometimes it's a split.
Because one of us is researching
one thing, and one of us
is researching the other thing.
It's like, well, we
have to have couscous,
because I've been reading
about Moroccan food all day.
It's like, couscous?
Why would you want couscous?
You need noodles tonight.
So that's just an easy
question to ask yourself.
It's like, what country
do I want to be in?
And then it's like, OK,
then you go in and grab
everything you have at home.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Super fun.
Super fun.
So Dede is plating the
demonstration plate up.
And the team behind you is
going to plate up the samples.
What I'd like to do now is to
open it up to any questions
that we might have while the
authors are here and finishing
the plate up.
And then we'll have
a quick sampling,
and then we'll do a
book signing after that.
So if there are
initial questions,
just start raising your hands.
If not, I'll just keep
gabbing, because I don't
have this opportunity often.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: My question is--
it seems quite a
beautiful, nice, big book.
So any suggestions of-- should
we just start at the beginning
and go through the end, or are
there parts where you're like,
it's OK to kind of flip over--
KAREN PAGE: It's
totally meant to be--
ANDREW DORNENBURG:
It is designed--
KAREN PAGE:
--flipping through it.
You flip through A
to Z. Anything that
catches your attention,
it catches your attention
for a reason.
I think flipping through
it is the absolute best
way to read the book.
You can read it chronologically.
It's laid out in a
chronological manner.
But you don't have to.
I would say, pick it up
whenever you need inspiration,
and we wrote it to be
there for when you do.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI:
So the question,
just repeat it for the
audience that are on video is,
is there a starting
point in the book?
And I think you
captured it great--
there could be, but
there doesn't have to be.
And I think that that would be
the same for many of the books
that you have.
Is I literally was in
"Culinary Artistry"
just a few days ago, not because
of the fact you were here,
but I had some questions
just around ingredients
that I needed to write for
a menu for the Montana then.
And I needed a
little inspiration.
And I was not feeling
creative at the moment.
I'm like, help me, Karen.
Help me, Andrew.
And so you can definitely
use those books any time
as resources.
And I think what
you're going to find
in this one is you can do that
even more so, because there's
so much good stuff in here with
all the chef tips, the quotes.
Amazing.
Additional questions
from the audience?
In the front, and then
we'll go to the back.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Question for Dede.
How did you season the
roasted vegetables?
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: How did you
season the roasted vegetables?
DEDE SAMPSON: Yeah,
just a little bit
of olive oil, and
salt and pepper.
So it's really simple.
That way you could really
take this base dish here
in a variety of directions.
So if I was feeling more
Mediterranean today,
I could have done lemons
and feta or Parmesan and--
or some champagne vinegar.
Maybe some basil.
So keeping your sort of--
my core road map simple--
plus we have leftovers.
Today is Thai.
Tomorrow can be Mediterranean.
And it's like a whole new dish.
KAREN PAGE: That's how we season
at home for the exact reasons.
You want the
flexibility if you want
to be in a different
country the next day.
If you season it
upfront with something
that's very identifiable
with a specific cuisine,
you're going to
have-- you're going
to stay in that country the
next day and the next day
until you use it up.
ANDREW DORNENBURG: But the other
thing we do at home-- sorry--
is we never call it leftovers.
We call it encores.
We're having an encore.
It's like, oh, we are?
Yeah.
You just sell it a
little bit, you know?
But I think--
DEDE SAMPSON:
Planned-overs, right?
Planned-overs.
KAREN PAGE: Planned-overs.
ANDREW DORNENBURG:
Planned-overs.
DEDE SAMPSON: Yeah.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI:
What's really interesting,
and to add your question, is--
I know what you're
getting at, which
is what do I need to do
to get to that end result?
And you know, you
could use butter.
You could use oil.
It doesn't really
matter at this point.
You obviously chose oil
because it's neutral
and it's a little lighter fat.
But what you've done really
well in this is the technique.
You've found a way to
dice these in a way
that they're a consistent size.
So they're going to cook evenly.
You found a way to brown
them off so that they still
have texture and caramelization,
but they're not mushy,
nor are they crunchy.
These are the things that
make or break a great meal
and take a little bit of
time to think through.
But nice job on that.
There was a question
in the back.
And we're going to
repeat the question
just so we can get it on--
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
how you approach--
ANDREW DORNENBURG: So what's
the entire process like?
KAREN PAGE: What's the
entire process when it comes
to the research for our books?
And this one in particular--
for this book, we
had both a bottom-up
and a top-down approach,
where the bottom-up approach
was basically talking to
chefs about what they felt
was important to know about
their creative process,
about how they cooked.
And all of them have
different specialties.
Some of them have different
countries that they specialize
or different techniques that
they specialize in, something
that roots their cuisine and
makes it different from anyone
else's.
And so we wanted to
understand, from talking
to Kyle Connaughton, a single
thread about his influences
in working in Japan and
that Japanese sensibility
that he brings to his food in
conjunction to the crazy stuff
that he's doing with
Heston Blumenthal
and that he'd learned at El
Bulli, working at El Bulli.
So he sort of brings
it all together
in a really interesting way.
Other people like Rick Bayless
from Frontera Grill in Chicago
is much more specialized
in Mexican cuisine.
And so we wanted to
really understand that
by talking to Rick.
We talked to his
chef de cuisine.
And we really wanted to
understand their approach
to thinking about things.
And the beautiful
thing about it is
that when you talk to people who
are the best at what they do,
they've been doing it, in
some cases, for decades.
And that creativity is
reflected in an evolution
that their cuisine goes through,
the evolution of their thought
process, where they're
designing a new menu
and had brainstormed
a list of adjectives
that best described
certain dishes.
So they organize their menu
not by appetizer, entree,
and dessert, but
by characteristic.
So it shows the level of thought
process that they put into it.
They also use inspiration
by different paintings
and different works of
art in their restaurant.
They will come up with dishes
that are a reflection of that.
So the research is extensive
in terms of speaking to chefs.
We also do extensive research
on restaurant reviews,
trying to understand
their restaurants
from a local
critic's perspective.
We review their cookbooks.
We review their menus.
And then we kind of put it
all together and kind of
bring it all together.
We also studied
creativity from the point
of view of various
experts on creativity.
So we spoke to experts like
Michael Gelb, the author
of "How to Think
Like Leonardo da
Vinci," and "The
Art of Connection"
on how do you really bring
those elements of creativity?
What are the things that
we should be looking for?
And he has identified some
of the key genius thinking
attributes of Leonardo da Vinci.
We saw them in the world's
most creative chefs.
And so I think through that
opportunity of really bringing
the two together,
we saw how chefs
were the perfect
exemplars of some
of the best creativity that's
going on in the world today.
And to really take a look
at their best practices
and really try to
translate that for anyone,
whether it's a professional
chef or a home cook,
to help you to be more
creative when you least feel
the inspiration to be creative.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Excellent.
So we have one or
two more questions.
So one thing that I'm
taking away from this,
and I'm hoping you are
as well, is the thought
and intentionality,
depending on whoever
you are that's creating
something, is immense.
And when you are preparing
your next meal or when
you're at a restaurant--
I would say when you're
preparing your own meal
or someone else is
cooking for you,
specifically at home,
turn off the TV.
You know, turn off
the distractions.
And take a few minutes to really
be mindful of the experience
that someone else
has prepared for you
or that you've
prepared for yourself.
And the reason I mention
that-- and this is in the book
as well--
is music and other
distractions can either enhance
or completely detract
from the experience.
And knowing the
thought that went
into just something
as simple as a salad,
and it's just not
a simple dish--
and it was delicious,
by the way.
That roasted mushroom?
DEDE SAMPSON: Right?
Yes.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: That
was like the winning hook
there that got me to go for
the next bite was the mushroom.
But think about that as
you're creating things.
And have a conversation
with people
when you're cooking
for them, because this
is what it's all about.
And the reason I mention
turning down the TV
is it's so easy just to be
mindless and just, you know,
it's not dining anymore.
It's just kind of feeding.
And we all do that at times.
But thank you for all the
work that you've done here.
Was there another
couple questions
before we line up
for signatures?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Holidays
are coming up,
and we have some big,
very traditional meals.
Do you have any advice for
how to inject creativity
into those occasions?
KAREN PAGE: Great question.
You know, a lot of times
it's very personal.
The holidays are times that
we typically get together
with family or
friends, loved ones,
and there's a lot of childhood
memories that are involved.
Andrew and I, our families
had different stuffings
when we were growing up.
So now we have a multiple
stuffing celebration
this time of year.
But a lot of times, you
know, there's a sacredness.
You don't always want--
creativity isn't
always a good thing.
Daniel Ballou says if
you're making steak frites,
you let it be steak frites.
You don't want to get
too creative with that.
Sometimes there is sacred
cows or sacred turkeys
when it comes to
Thanksgiving that you
don't want to mess with.
If you want to have
a happy Thanksgiving
and have it be as
peaceful and calm around
the table as possible,
you don't want to mess
with people's favorite dishes.
But there are times
that you can take
what the essence
of Thanksgiving is,
and if you can deconstruct, what
is it that's important to you?
Well, I want to have a
pumpkin dessert on the table.
It doesn't have
to be pumpkin pie.
And then you can
start playing with it.
OK, am I going to
do a pumpkin tart?
Am I going to do
a pumpkin ravioli?
Am I going to make
it a side dish?
You know, how am I
going to play with that?
Am I going to come up
with a pumpkin cocktail?
So you can have--
you know, there's
a place in New York City where
we had a turkey sandwich that
was served with a bag
of sweet potato chips
and a cranberry fizzy drink.
And you realize all the
flavors of Thanksgiving
are right there, but they're in
a completely different format.
If you can take the--
figure it out, you know,
do the deconstruction
of what are the flavors
that mean Christmas to you
or Hanukkah to you or
Thanksgiving to you
and narrow them down.
And it's like, OK, well,
I have to have stuffing,
or I have to have gravy,
or whatever your thing is--
sorry?
DEDE SAMPSON: Or champagne.
KAREN PAGE: Well,
always champagne.
Always champagne.
Right.
So you can play with that.
We have an exercise in the
beginning of stage three
in the book where we ask you
to think about what your five
favorite childhood dishes
were and to really analyze
the information that's
packed in there,
because we think
that all of you know
more than you think you know.
And it's all packed in your
favorite childhood dishes.
So if you take a minute and
just sort of make a mental note,
it's like, oh, yeah, my mom's
blank or my grandmother's blank
or my father's blank when
he pulled up the grill
and made this for me
when I was growing up.
Figure out what those dishes
were and then think about what
made the dish special to you.
So for me, it was
caramel apples.
And you'll see a caramel apple
example of different dishes
you can make with the
combination of apple,
caramel, and nuts that are other
than a whole apple on a stick.
So we've got a salad example.
We've got a cocktail
example, different desserts,
you know, an upscale
dessert example, using
that same set of
flavor affinities,
or flavor chords,
as we called them,
but in a whole different way.
And if you take that simple
example and you apply it
to whatever your
favorite flavors are,
whether it's tomato,
basil, and Parmesan cheese,
or something completely
different-- garlic, ginger,
and soy sauce--
you can take that set
of compatible flavors
and apply it to a whole
host of different dishes.
And that will get your
creativity going very quickly.
ANDREW DORNENBURG: I would
just add one more thing.
We'll use Thanksgiving,
because that's a biggie.
When you make your cranberry
sauce, take half of it
and make it a different way.
So have the one that's going
to make everyone happy--
it's Thanksgiving,
for God's sake--
but maybe take another one
and look up cranberries.
Think about cranberries
like, you know,
I think I'll pop
some ginger in there,
or maybe a little turmeric
or a little orange zest.
And that might not be
your family's typical one,
but then you'll
have something new.
And we went vegetarian
five years ago.
And we were invited
to Thanksgiving.
So guess what?
I learned how to make
mushroom gravy that year.
And now going on
five years, I'm still
working on mushroom gravy,
mushroom gravy, mushroom gravy.
So again, just add--
you know, have the
classic thing that,
again, makes everyone
happy, but then
just throw in a
couple extra dishes.
And, like what's two extra
dishes at Thanksgiving,
you know?
You sort of point it
out, like, this is new.
And that's also a
fun way to do it,
because also, it'll
give you a chance
to sort of chill out
around Thanksgiving,
make something new.
You're already in
the kitchen anyway.
But just do half.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Excellent.
Well, I know we're at time.
I know there's more questions.
What I'd like to do is
first give both of you
a huge round of
applause for coming.
Thank you.
KAREN PAGE: Thank
you for having us.
[APPLAUSE]